It was five days before my ten-year high school reunion when my husband told me he thought
he might be gay.
He wasn't sure he was gay because he had never been with a man yet, but he thought it was
something he ought to figure out.
Good idea.
Now I think he told me this at that moment, not to get out of my high school reunion,
which would be understandable, but in order to, because we had been looking for houses
together and we'd finally found one in Pasadena that we both liked.
And I think somehow the forever of a wedding vow sounded kind of vague and idealistic to
him where his 30-year mortgage was surprisingly specific.
It was a commitment, you know, the kind of commitment you shouldn't make while your sexuality
is pending.
Now, as he was explaining this to me, I was thinking downstairs, our neighbors, we lived
in this duplex apartment we were renting, the Kaufmans were probably just sitting down
to dinner as they'd done for 52 years and talking about their brisket, and they were
this couple that used to come up and see our new furniture, like when we bought a new antique
table because Sam liked antique shopping, pink flag, and so they were like parent figures
to us.
And, you know, there were signs, like when I first met Sam, he had this leather jacket
with tiger print lining, and I remember thinking it seemed kind of, the lining, I don't know
it stuck with me.
And then, you know, but then he asked me out, and we slept together, and he asked me to
marry him, and I put on the big white dress, which he helped me pick out in front, seriously,
in front of, you know, 200 of my closest friends, and I figured he's not.
And also, I actually, I guess there was one thing I ignored, which I probably should have
paid attention to.
He told me before we were, while we were engaged, he told me he sometimes noticed men, but he
said he couldn't imagine sleeping with a man, and, you know, he just noticed them.
And I guess I knew this was not good because I didn't talk to any girlfriends about this,
and I talk to girlfriends about everything.
So if I didn't, it was probably bad.
But I did, at one point, I did talk to one girlfriend, we were in line at Disneyland
for Space Mountain, and I told her how Sam had said he sometimes noticed men, and do
you think that's bad?
And she said, you know, she told me this theory of the spectrum of sexuality, and everyone
lies somewhere along it, and some people notice people, but they would never act on it.
Four years later, she realized she was a lesbian.
My one person I confess to.
So as I was recalling all these signs, I realized Sam was still talking, and he was telling
me he felt so much better getting this off his chest, and he'd been wanting to tell me
for a long time, and he felt so relieved, he kind of wanted to have sex.
And I said, with who?
And he said, with you.
And I think he meant it as a compliment, but I have to go to bed and wake up when the bookstores
are open.
So the next day, I went directly to the self-help section, where all problems could be solved,
and there was no book for someone whose husband thought he might be gay.
There was a book called Loving Someone Gay, but it turned out to be for teachers and family
members, but nothing.
And I was nervous because this is LA, and I didn't want to pioneer a problem.
This is a very bad sign.
And as I'm looking for a book, any book, I remember I saw one called How to Survive Alien
Abduction, and it wasn't a humor book, it was a serious book with things like block
their mind control and get help from on high.
And so basically, according to the laws of supply and demand, you're more likely to be
abducted by an alien than to have your husband realize he's gay.
That's what that said to me.
And so I left the self-help section despondent and decided that it was time to go to therapy.
Four days now from my high school reunion.
So I went for the first time.
I had never gone to therapy.
I grew up in Oklahoma, which is where my reunion was going to be.
And I went, there was this thing called the Gold Group, because I was in the Writers Guild.
Basically when I became a comedy writer, I decided my husband no longer wanted to be
a straight man.
That was basically what happened there.
And so I was in the Writers Guild.
And they paid for this thing called the Gold Group, and it was a group of therapists in
the valley.
And it was only a $10 copay.
And it's possible you shouldn't skimp on therapy, but I thought I was going to be in for a while.
So I went to the Gold Group, and I remember when I got in there, you basically get what
you copay for because I was in this office waiting for my therapist, and I could hear
the session next to me.
It was this paper-thin wall, and I could hear a man sobbing, and I was like, they're going
to hear me sobbing.
And then when my therapist came in, she turned on this little oscillating fan, which I think
is the system the Gold Group had come up with to deal with the soundproofing problem.
And my therapist, and I didn't have anything to compare against, but I just remember noting
she was very badly dressed, like pink and red together and stripes, and I thought she
can't put together an outfit.
And she has to put together my whole life.
This is not good.
And she had all these questions I hadn't even thought of, like, should you be HIV tested
and maybe he's lying and he's been cheating on you?
And she had a lot of anger that we worked on.
So she felt better.
Okay, so I proceeded.
My decision was to go to the reunion with Sam and pretend everything was fine, because
it seemed better than, well, one problem was Sam wasn't ready to come out, because he hadn't
started.
See, when he told me he thought he might be gay, he said, maybe I'll only be 30% gay,
I'll find out, and then I could still be with you.
And I was overwhelmed at the moment, but I do remember thinking, so he'll sleep with
10 men and enjoy three of them?
I'm confused how we're going to do the math of this.
So he hadn't started that experiment yet.
So he wasn't ready to come out, because he didn't know yet.
So we just went to my reunion like that.
So we stayed with my parents, which is not a fun thing, even when your husband doesn't
think he might be gay.
And I remember at the reunion, I won most successful, and I just was like, yeah, my
husband's gay.
You know, it was Oklahoma, the runner-up was, like, the manager of the footlocker, so it
wasn't a huge honor.
But anyway, I remember when I went home, I was really nervous about my mom, because my
mom, it was like being, you know that scene in My Fair Lady when the linguistic experts
asked her to dance?
That's how it was being alone with my mom with a secret, because my mom, like right
now she would say, your voice sounds a little tight, honey, like she's very eagle-eye about
these emotional things.
And I kept worrying and trying to avoid her, and I completely forgot about my dad.
And at one point, he was sitting there watching ESPN, and he said, is everything okay?
And I said, no, you know, if everything was okay, Sam would be in here watching ESPN with
you instead of in the kitchen flipping through House Beautiful with mom.
And I basically told my dad everything, which is not the system in my house.
You tell my mom, and my mom tells my dad.
But I told my dad.
And then I remembered why I don't ever tell my dad, because he was like, it was like I
was asked, he thought it was as if Sam was asking permission to have an affair and I
should just say no.
So he's, in fact, his words were, I'd like to sleep with Debbie Reynolds, but your mom's
not going to let me.
I was like, but what if you want to sleep with Burt Reynolds?
And to his credit, he had no experience with this.
In college, he had had one, you know, there was one guy in his fraternity that everyone
knew had realized he was gay and left his wife and kids, Jerry Hovelman, and no one
had ever heard from him again.
And that was like his whole experience with the gay population.
So he was no help.
And somehow, though, Sam and I survived our my high school reunion, but Mr.
Kaufman, who lived downstairs, did not survive the weekend.
He had died in a sleep of a heart attack and there was a funeral.
And and I remember it was kind of a highlight for me because I had been crying in such
inappropriate places all week.
And finally, I was at a funeral and I could just sob, even though I think it was odd to
people because they were like, is she the tenant?
Because I was kind of like grabbing Kleenex from the mother.
You know, but I remember I was there with Sam and we were holding hands and we were
thinking I was thinking at least at a funeral, there's a body and a grave and
something tangible to mark the end.
And with the relationship, it's never so clearly marked.
And it was a relief to be there with Sam for closure.
And then it being a Jewish funeral, there was a need for a minion where they needed 10
men to go. And I remember thinking, don't go with the men to Sam.
I do not want him to go with the men.
But then finally, I said go.
And I realized I meant it in the largest sense possible.
And about a week later, my dad called me and he said, you know, it's really 99 percent
genetic, this whole homosexuality thing.
And I was completely thrown and thought maybe he'd been on the Internet and researching.
And it turned out that my dad had called Jerry Hovelman and asked him to lunch.
He had tracked down this man and took him to Denny's.
And I'm sure there were lots of disclaimers because my dad does not take men to lunch.
So he probably was afraid it would sound like a date or something.
And I'm sure when he showed up in shorts and black dress socks and loafers, it was clear
he was not of the gay persuasion.
But he asked Jerry all the things he wanted to ask, I guess, and couldn't like, could
you have avoided this?
And did you ever regret it?
And is your wife OK?
And it was maybe the nicest thing a father ever did, taking Jerry Hovelman to lunch.
And just about a week after that, Sam was finally moving out.
And I remember we were in the top floor of our duplex and downstairs, Mrs.
Kaufman was gardening like she always did.
And Sam hadn't talked to her yet because she was like a parent figure and he still
wasn't ready to come out.
And he wasn't dealing with things as he hadn't dealt with many things.
And so I said, you have to tell her because the moving van is going to be here any
minute and she's going to wonder because and he wouldn't.
So I went downstairs to talk to her.
And I remember she was she'd always loved gardening, but it was really about she seemed
more desperate than ever to kind of keep things alive, nurture the living things and
not to let things slip away.
And she couldn't imagine why I was letting my husband slip away.
And I couldn't explain to her.
And so we just sat together on this bench and shoulder to shoulder to women alone,
but not really alone as the moving van lumbered over to the sidewalk.
Thank you.